so Rob I was worried about you during
this movie
this was quite a physical and mental
toll taken on your character what was
the filming process like for you I'm a
kind of think most actors look for these
parts I think maybe cuz they're a little
bit mentally unstable in the first place
are you yeah as soon as you kind of see
it's quite rare to find somewhere you
can just go to real extremes and this is
definitely there was a couple of moments
where it's just you're going you're
you're pushing the accelerator down and
then just breaking it off though quite
sustained periods right for mines
what was the most extreme thing you did
for a scene I mean lots of different
things I think yeah I sort of there's a
lot of smashing things up and and I
think well it's kind of fun if you're
playing someone who's who's really at
the end of that's Heather like every the
crew kind of accepts that you're you can
just do whatever you want no this year
as yeah as kind of as I sort of build up
this scene and said it's kind of fun if
you just like ever before every single
thing the same you know just sitting
having dinner I want to do it now I'm
addicted to it did you get a little bit
pushing yourself for everything in this
yeah it was kind of you definitely expel
almost every bit of energy how day
that's addicting yeah this is so nice
man when you can go at home off is like
oh I sleep sound B I've been crazy all
day
I mean pushing yourself the water the
weather one positive though you had a
mustache and I read that you'd always
wanted to grow a mustache for a movie
and I thought it looked great
why not keep it it is I mean I think
it's quite shameful thing to have
mustache when you see when you see a guy
who's not unless you're like kind of you
work in an insurance or something really
really straight and it's like yeah you
okay I accept a mustache on
but if your kind of hipster mustache
it's a no on every level it were above
that yeah I thought it was good I think
they're back I think he could bring it
back a lot of awards recognition for
this movie and you know how would it
feel for you to get recognized I'm just
glad the movies getting recognized at
all I mean I kind of it's it's a very
it's kind of aggressively strange and
it's it's kind of I didn't I mean from
the script I'm not and I didn't I didn't
even fully get it when I first read it
right and then when I first saw it I
think it's so funny and so yeah so good
but I didn't I still didn't really know
if anyone else is gonna find it funny I
laughed yeah and like just hear people
laughing at it I was I was people liking
him it's very happy good last question
for you uh we're so excited for the
batman zoe kravitz comin at us as
Catwoman how worthy of an adversary as
she were you a big fan of hers yes oh
he's great
and I'm so and I've known a few years
and years and years I mean I've been
around stuff like ten years and so it's
uh yeah she's she's what is she what do
you think she's gonna bring to it I mean
a lot and she's uh yes she's no she's
brilliant so it's kind of so cool and
I'm just like a really really nice a
nice person as well alright a you and
Zoe showdown though I'm in yeah no
mustache for a minute okay alright thank
you so much thank you
[Music]
[Applause]